all right we're going to go ahead and
get started
homework - it should be well underway if
you have any questions feel free to
reach out to us project proposals if you
have questions about that feel free to
come to our office hours or to reach out
by our Piazza so they have any other
questions I can answer right now all
right so today we're gonna start this is
a little bit loud today we're gonna
start talking about policy gradient
methods policy gradient methods are
probably the most well used in
reinforcement learning right now um so I
think they're an incredibly useful thing
to be familiar with whenever we talk
about reinforcement learning we sort of
keep coming back to these main
properties that we'd like about agents
that learn to make decisions about them
being able to do the sort of
optimization handling delayed
consequences during exploration and do
it all sort of statistically and
efficiently in really high dimensional
spaces and what we were started talking
about last time in terms of imitation
learning was sort of a different way to
kind of provide additional structure or
additional support for our agents um so
that they could try to learn how to do
things faster and imitation learning was
one way to provide structure or support
by leveraging demonstrations from people
and we've seen other ways to sort of an
encode structure or human prior
knowledge when we started talking about
function approximation so when we think
about how we define Q like when we
define Q as si and W where this was a
set of parameters we were implicitly
making a choice about sort of imposing
some structure in terms of how we were
going to represent our value function
and that choice might be fairly strong
like assuming it was linear so this is
sort of a quite a strong assumption or
it might be a very weak assumption like
using a deep neural net and so when we
specify answer these function
approximations of representations we're
sort of implicitly making choices about
how much structure and how much domain
knowledge we want to put in
in order for our agents to learn so what
we're gonna start to talk about today
and we're trying to talk about this week
is policy search which is another place
where it can be very natural to put in
domain knowledge and we'll see that in
some robotics examples today and it can
be also a very efficient way to try to
learn so as I was saying before we sort
of we're approximating where we're doing
model free reinforcement learning and
when we started to try to scale up to
really large state spaces I've been
having it several different people ask
me about really large action spaces
which is a really important topic we're
not going to talk too much about that in
this quarter though we will talk a
little bit about when your action space
is continuous but low dimensional but we
have started to talk a lot about when
the state space is really high
dimensional and really large and so we
talked about approximating things with
some sort of parameterization like
whether it be parameters theta or we
offer or we often use W but some sort of
parameterization of the function and so
we used our value function to define
expected discounted sum of rewards from
a particular State or state action and
then we could extract a policy from that
value function or at least from a state
action value function and instead what
we're gonna do today is just directly
parameterize the policy so when we
talked about tabular policies our policy
was just a mapping from States to
actions and in the tabular setting we
could just look do that as a lookup
table for every single state we could
write down what action we would take and
what we're gonna do now is to say well
it's not going to be feasible to write
down our table of our policy so instead
what we're gonna do is parameterize it
we're gonna use a set of weights or
theta is today we're mostly going to use
theta is but this is well think of this
as weights just some way to parameterize
our policy I will talk more about
particular forms of parameterization but
just like what we saw for state action
value functions this is gonna have a big
implication because this is effectively
defining the space that you couldn't
learn over so sort of it's determining
the the class of policies you could poss
learn I'm wearing engines terrific was
on model free reinforcement learning
meaning that we're not going to assume
that we have access to and a priori
model of the dynamics or reward of the
world so we've had through some of these
diagrams up at the start of the quarter
I just want to go back to it we've been
talking about sort value we haven't
talked so much about models though
models are also super important but
we've been talking a lot about sort of
value function based approaches which is
this and now we're gonna talk about
policy direct policy search methods and
as you might expect there's a lot of
work which tries to combine between the
two of them these are often called extra
critic methods we try to explicitly
maintain a parametrized policy and
explicitly maintain a parameterised
critic or value function so this is the
policy and this is a cue we're gonna
start today and we're going to be
talking about policy based methods so
why would you want to do this well it
actually goes back a little bit to also
what we're talking about last week with
imitation learning for imitation
learning we talked about the fact that
sometimes it's hard for humans to write
down a reward function and so it might
be easier for them just to demonstrate
what the policy looks like similarly in
some cases maybe it's easier to write
down sort of a parameterization of the
space of policies than it is to write
down a parameterization of the space of
state action value functions in addition
they're often much more effective in
high dimensional or continuous action
spaces and they allow us to learn
stochastic policies which we haven't
talked very much about so far but I'm
going to give you some illustrations
about where we definitely want
stochastic policies and they sometimes
have better convergent policy
convergence properties that can be a
little bit debated it depends exactly
what whether we're comparing that to
model for your model bet based
approaches and how much computation
we're doing and so this can be a little
bit of a function of computation to
computation come matter what are the
really big disadvantages is that they
are typically only going to converge to
a local Optima
so we're you're going to converge to
something that is hopefully a pretty
good policy but we're not generally
guaranteed to converge to the global
Optima now there are some techniques
that are guaranteed to converge the
local up into the global Optima and I'll
try to highlight some of those today but
generally almost all of the methods that
you see in like deep reinforcement
learning that our policy gradient-based
only converts to a local optima and then
the other challenge is that typically
we're gonna do this by trying to
evaluate a policy and then estimate its
gradient and often that can be somewhat
sample inefficient so we might be quite
a lot of data to estimate what that
gradient is when we're taking a gradient
based approach so why might we want sort
of a stochastic policy so in what I
mentioned before in the tabular setting
so let me just go back to here so in now
why do we want this want this if you
think back to sort of the very first
lectures what I said is that if we have
a tabular MDP there exists a pie which
is deterministic and optimal so in the
tabular MDP setting we do not need deter
we do not need stochastic policies
because there always exists a policy
this is deterministic that has the same
value as the optimal policy does so this
is not needed in the tabular Markov
decision process case but we don't
always we're not always acting in the
tabular of Markov decision process case
so as an example who here is familiar
with rock-paper-scissors most people and
I possibly if you're not you might have
played it by another name so in
rock-paper-scissors it's a two-player
game everyone can either pick paper or
scissors or rock when you have to pick
one of those and scissors beats paper
paper at rock beats scissors and paper
beats rock and in this case if you had a
deterministic policy you could lose
you could easily be exploited by the
other agent but a uniform random policy
is basically optimal what do I mean by
optimality in this case I mean that you
you get a say a plus one if you win and
let's say zero minus one if you lose now
we're not going to talk too much about
multi-agent cases in this class but it's
a super interesting area of research and
in this case you know the environment is
not agnostic and the environment can
react to the policies that we're doing
and can be adversarial and so we want a
policy that is robust to an adversary so
a second case is alias grid world so so
in this case so why you know why is
being stochastic you important here well
because we're not really in a stochastic
setting we're in an adversarial setting
we have another agent that is playing
with us and they can be non-stationary
and changing their policy and respond
stars so it's not a the environment
doesn't pick the next it doesn't pick
rock-paper-scissors regardless of our
actions and in the past it can respond
to those so it's sort of got this non
stationarity or adversarial nature in
other cases where it's not Markov so
it's really partially observable and you
have aliasing which means that we can't
distinguish between multiple states in
terms of our sensors so we thought this
before a little bit when we talked about
robots that you know could have laser
rangefinders and sort of tell where they
were in a hallway by how far away each
of the the the first point of obstacle
was for all of their 180 degrees and so
that would look the same in lots of
different hallways so this is a simple
example of that so in an alias grid
world let's say that the agent because
of their sensors cannot distinguish the
gray States and they have features of a
particular form they have a feature for
whether or not there's a wall to the
north or east or south or west so it can
basically like if it's here it can tell
like oh I have walls to either side of
me and not in front or behind me but
that could be the same over in that in
the other grades date
so if we did a value-based reinforcement
learning approach using some sort of
approximate value function it would take
these features which are a combination
of what action am I going to take and
whether there are walls around me or not
or we could have a policy based approach
which also takes in these features but
then just directly tries to make
decisions about what action to take and
those actions can be stochastic so in
this case the agent is trying to figure
out how to navigate in this world it
really wants to get to here
this is where there's a large reward so
this is good it wants to avoid the skull
and crossbones and those will be
negative reward so because of the
aliasing the agent can't distinguish
whether or not it's here or here and so
it has to do the same thing in both
states and so either it has to go left
or it has to go right west or east and
either way that's not optimal because if
it's actually here it should be going
that way not over here and down and so
it can distinguish whether it's in here
or here but it could just end up moving
back and forth they are making very bad
decisions and so it can get stuck and
never be able to know what it's safe to
go down and reach the money so it learns
in a deterministic policy because that's
what we've normally been learning with
these and and whether it's greedy or a
greedy in general it will do very poorly
but if you have a stochastic policy when
you're in a state where you're aliased
you could just randomize you could say
I'm not sure whether I'm actually in
this state in this state or this state
so I'll just go I either east or west
with 50% probability and then it'll
generally reach the goal state quickly
because note it can tell what it should
do when it reaches here because that
looks different than these two states so
once it's in the middle it knows exactly
what to do so that's just again an
example where a stochastic policy has a
way better value than a deterministic
policy and that's because the domain
here is not Markov its partially
observable
okay so that's sort of one of the
reasons why we might want some of the
reasons why we might want to be directly
policy-based and there's a lot of other
reasons so so what does this mean well
we're gonna have this parametrize policy
and the goal is that we want to find
yeah so what can we conclude that if the
world is partially observable stochastic
policies are always better I think it
depends on the modeling you want to do I
think in this case better than being
stochastic because it's still doing
something kind of not very intelligent
in the gray states it's just randomizing
would be to have a partially observable
Markov decision process policy and then
you could track an estimate over where
you are in the world so you could keep
track of a belief state over what state
you're in and then you could hopefully
uniquely identify that oh if I was just
in this state I have to be in this state
now and then you could deterministically
go to the right or left so it depends on
on the modeling ones willing to do good
question okay so when we start to do to
go to parametrize policy search what
we're gonna want to do is find the
parameters that yield the best value the
policy in the class with the best value
and so similar to what we've seen before
we can it we can think about served
episodic settings and infinite for
continuing settings so in an episodic
setting that means that the agent will
act for a number of time steps often
let's say H steps but it could be
variable like it might be until you
reach you know a terminal state and then
we can just consider what is the
expected value or what is the value
what's the expected discounted summer of
rewards we get from a start state or a
distribution of start states and then
what we want to do is find the
parametrized policy that has the highest
value another option is that if we're at
a continued environment which means
we're in the online setting we don't act
for H steps we just act forever
there's no terminal states and we can
either use the
average value where we average over the
distribution of states so this is like
what we saw before thinking about the
distribution the stationary distribution
over there Markov chain that is induced
by a particular policy because we talked
about before about the fact that if you
fix the policy and then basically you
get in a Markoff forward process you can
also just think of the distribution of
states you get is a Markov chain so if
we're acting forever we're going to say
sort of on average what is the value of
the states that we reach under that
stationary distribution and another way
to do it is also to say we just look at
sort of the average reward per time step
now for simplicity today we're going to
focus almost exclusively on the episodic
setting but we can think about similar
techniques for these other forms of
settings so as before and this is an
optimization problem similar to what we
saw in the value function approximation
case for linear value functions and
using deep neural networks we're gonna
want to be doing optimization which
means that we need to do some sort of
optimization tool to try to search for
the best data so one option is to do
gradient free optimization we don't tend
to do this very much in policy search
methods but there are lots of different
methods that our gradient freeze
optimization just for us to find
whatever parameters maximize this be
pious data and just to connect this just
like what we saw for Q functions now we
have theta which is specifying a policy
and it maybe have some interesting
landscape and then we want to be able to
find where is the max so we're really
trying to find the max of a function as
efficiently as we can and there are lots
of methods for doing that that don't
rely on the function being
differentiable and these actually can be
very good in some cases so this is some
nice work done by a colleague of mine
and we have developed a method for
automatically identifying the
exoskeleton assistance patterns that
minimize metabolic energy cost for
individual humans during walk
during optimization the user first
experiences one control law while
respiratory measurements are taken
steady state energy cost is estimated by
fitting a first-order dynamical model to
two minutes of transient data the
control law is then changed and
metabolic rate is estimated again this
process is repeated for a prescribed
number of control loss forming one
generation a covariance matrix
adaptation evolution strategy is then
used to create the next generation the
mean of each generation represents the
best estimate of the optimal control
parameter values after about an hour of
optimization energy cost was reduced by
an average of 24 percent compared to no
assistance so this is work that's done
by my colleague Steve Collins who's over
in mechanical engineering and we've been
collaborating someone whether you can
train people to do this better so the
idea in this case is that there's lots
of instances for which you'd like to use
exoskeletons I'm a lot of people have
strokes a lot of people with mobility
problems and of course there's a lot of
veterans that lose a limb and in these
cases one of the challenges has been is
how do you sort of figure out what are
the parameters of these exoskeletons in
order to provide support for people
walking and then generally it varies on
physiology and for many different people
they're gonna need different types of
parameters but you want to do this
really quickly so you want to be able to
figure out very fast for each individual
what is the right control parameters in
order to help them get the most
assistance as they walk and so Steve's
labs treated this as sort of a policy
policy search problem where what you're
doing is you're having somebody where
their device you're trying some control
laws that are providing a particular
form of support in terms of their
exoskeleton you're measuring their sort
of metabolic efficiency which is how do
you know how hard are they breathing how
hard are they having to work compared to
if they weren't wearing this or under
different control laws and then you can
use this information to figure out
what's the next set of control laws you
use and do this all in a closed-loop
fashion as quickly as possible now one
of the reasons I bring this up
is both because it was incredibly
effective it's a really nice science
paper that illustrates how this could be
much more effective than previous
techniques and second because it was
using CM AES which is a gradient free
approach so even though most of what
we're gonna discuss today in class is
all with gradient based methods there's
some really nice examples of not using
gradient based methods also to do policy
search for lots of other types of
applications so I think it's useful to
sort of know in your toolbox that one
doesn't have to be constrained to
gradient based methods and one of the
really nice things about things like
CMAs is that they're guaranteed to get
towards a to a global Optima so in some
cases you might really want to be
guaranteed that you're doing that
because it's a high-stakes situation and
in general it sort of is it has been
noticed repeatedly recently that
sometimes these sort of approaches do
work kind of embarrassing me well um
that tend to be in some way sort of a
brute force a smart brute force way and
that often can be very effective so
they're good to consider in terms of the
applications you look at but you know
despite this even though they can be
really good and sometimes they're very
very helpful for paralyzation i they're
generally not very sample efficient and
so depending on the domain that you're
looking at and what sort of structure
you have often it's useful to go to a
gradient based method particularly if
you might be satisfied with a local
solution at the end sort of locally
optimal so what we're going to talk
about mostly today just like what we did
for value like value based methods is
gradient descent ingredient based
methods and other methods that try to
exploit the sequential structure of
decision making problems so CMEs doesn't
know anything about the fact that this
the world might be an MDP or any Porter
of sort of sequential stochastic process
and we're going to focus on ones that
sort of leverage the structure of the
Markov decision process and the decision
process itself so let's talk about
policy gradient methods we're again just
sort of defined things in terms of theta
so that we're explicit about the
parameter and we're gonna focus on
episodic MDPs which means that we're
gonna run our policy if a certain number
of time steps until we terminal state or
certain you know maybe
eight steps we're gonna get some reward
during that time period and then we're
gonna reset so we're going to be looking
for a local maximum and we're going to
be taking the gradient with respect to
the parameters that define the policy
and then use some small learning rate so
just this is this should look very
similar very similar to the similar to Q
and V based search and the main
difference here is that instead of
taking the derivative with respect to
parameters that define our Q function
we're taking them with respect to the
parameters that define our policy so the
simplest thing to do here is to do
finite differences
so for each of your policy parameters
you just perturb it a little bit and if
you do that for everything one of the
dimensions that define your policy
parameters then you're going to get an
estimate of the gradient you're just
doing sort of a finite differences
estimate of the gradient and you could
use a certain number of evaluations for
doing this in each of the cases so you
can let's say you have this K
dimensional set of parameters that
defined your policy you try changing one
of them a little bit you repeat it you
get a bunch of samples for that new
policy you do that for all of the
different dimensions and now you have an
approximation of the gradient it's very
simple quite noisy and it's not
particularly efficient but can sometimes
be effective and it was one of the
earlier demonstrations of how policy
gradient methods could be very useful in
an RL context and the nice thing is that
the policy itself doesn't have to be
differentiable because we're just doing
sort of a finite difference
approximation of the gradient so what
are the first examples that I see I
think of when I think of sort of how
policy gradient methods or how policy
search methods can be really effective
is Peter stones work on doing a RoboCup
and who here has ever seen like Robocop
okay a few people
not everybody so let's see if we can get
up like a short demonstration of like
what these robots look like so it's okay
so you probably can't see it do you we
won't do that right now
but essentially what you have is there's
a bunch of different leagues of Robocop
one of the goals has been that I think
by 2050 the goal is that we're gonna
have a robotic soccer team that is gonna
be able to defeat like able to you know
win the World Cup so that's been one of
the driving goals of the sort of the
Robocop initiative and there's a lot of
different leagues within this and one of
them is these sort of cuatro ped
robots um which try to score goals
against each other and one of the key
challenges for this is that they look
kind of like that and you have to figure
out the gate for walking and you want
them to be able to walk quickly but you
don't want them to fall over and so just
simply that question of like how do you
optimize the gate is an important
question in order to win because you
need your robots to move fast on the
field so Peter stone has been a leading
person in in Robocop for a long time
and their goal was simply to learn a
fast way for these AI bows to walk and
to do it by real experience and data is
really important here because it's
expensive like you have these robots
walking back and forth and you want them
to very quickly optimize their gait and
you don't have to keep changing
batteries and things like that so you
really want to do this with very little
amounts of data so what they thought of
doing in this case is sort of to do a
parametrized policy and try to optimize
those proper policies so this is where
significant domain knowledge came in and
this is a way to inject domain knowledge
so they specified it by this sort of
continuous ellipse of how gate works for
this small robot and so they
parameterize it by these twelve
continuous parameters and this
completely defines the space of possible
policies you could learn this might not
be optimal Peter stone and his group
have a huge amount of experience on
doing RoboCup at the time they're doing
this paper and so they really had a lot
of knowledge they could inject in here
and in some ways it's a way to provide
sort of this hierarchical structure
about what sort of policies might be
good
and then what they did is they just did
this method of finite difference in in
order to try to optimize for all of
these parameters so one of the important
things here is that all of their policy
evaluations we're going to be done on
actual real robots and they just wanted
to have people in to intervene every
once in a while in order to replace
batteries which took happen about once
an hour and so they did it on three I
BOS very small amount of hardware they
did about fifteen policies per iteration
and they evaluated each policy three
times so it's not very many that can be
a very noisy signal and each iteration
took about seven point five minutes so
and then they had to pick some learning
rate and so what do we see in this case
well we see that in terms of the number
of iterations that they have versus how
quickly they're of course you have to
define your optimization criteria in
this case they're looking at speed of
stable walking and a lot of people have
been trying to figure out how to do
these using hand tuning before including
so they're the UT Austin Villa team
including them in the past people have
found different ways to sort of hand
tune and I don't know if I'm using
supervised learning cetera and you can
see as they do multiple iterations of
trying to search for a better policy
using this finite difference method that
they get to faster than everything else
and this is not that many iterations so
this is something that was happening you
know over you know a few hours so I
think this is a really compelling
example of how policy gradient methods
could really do much better than what
had happened before and they didn't have
to require enormous amount of data
that's very different than probably what
you're experiencing an assignment to so
this is no total number of iterations I
think this was on the order of let's see
like no this is on the order of you know
tens to hundreds of policies not
millions and millions of steps so these
things can be very data efficient but
there was also a lot of information that
was given so if you think about sort of
like a little bit on here so in their
paper they discussed it of what was
actually impacting performance in this
case and there's a lot of things that
impact performance so you know how do we
start
so may have a sense what you know why
does the initial policy parameters used
matter for this type of method
guaranteed to have a global optimum only
a local optimum so your starting point
is going to affect which local property
are able to so what just said is that
because these methods are only
guaranteed particularly this method is
only guaranteed to find a local optima
and all of the sort of policy gradient
style methods are then wherever you
start you're going to get to the closest
local optima and you have no guarantee
that that's the best global Optima so
it's important to either try lots of
random restarts here in this case or to
have domain knowledge another important
question here is how much you perturbing
sort of the size of your finite
differences and then I think really most
critical is this policy parameterization
like just how are you writing down the
space of possible policies that you can
learn with it because that's not a good
policy space then you're just not going
to learn anything yeah yeah
so especially was about the open loop
policy part so these policies that we're
learning don't have to be adaptive an
open loop policy is essentially a plan
it's a sequence of actions to take
regardless of any additional input that
you might have so we typically been
thinking about policies as mappings from
States to actions but they can also just
be a series of actions and so when we
talk about an open loop policy that's a
non reactive policy because it's just a
sequence of actions that regardless of
the state of the robot you just keep
going so maybe there's a really large
wind in the middle and the robots next
action is the same whether there's a lot
of wind or not it doesn't have to be
reactive
okay so but in general you know finite
differences is a reasonable thing to try
often we're gonna want to use gradient
information and leverage the fact that
our policy for function is actually
differentiable so what we're gonna do
now is compute the policy gradient
analytically excuse me this is most
common in most the techniques that are
used right now we're gonna assume it's
differentiable wherever it's nonzero and
that we can explicitly compute this so
when we say what we when we say we know
that means that this is computable we
can compute this explicitly and so now
we're gonna be thinking only about
gradient based methods and so we're only
we're gonna only converge to a local
optima hopefully hopefully we'll get to
a local optima that's the best we can
hope for in this case okay so we're
going to talk people often talk about
likelihood ratio policies and they're
gonna sort of proceed as follows
so we're think about the episodic case
so we're gonna think about it as having
trajectories so state action or word
next state etc all the way out to some
terminal State this is where we
terminate and we're gonna use R of tau
to denote the sum of rewards for a
trajectory so the policy value in this
case is just gonna be the expected count
at some rewards we get by following this
policy and we can represent that as the
probability that we observed a
particular trajectory times the reward
of that trajectory so it just says given
under this policy what are the you know
what's the probability of seeing any
trajectory and then what would be the
reward of that trajectory because the
reward is just a deterministic function
of the trajectory once you know the
state action rewards etc then your
reward is just the sum of all of those
and so now in this particular notation
what our goal will be is to find policy
parameters theta which are the arguments
of this and the reason we've through
what what have we changed here the
change now bin has
the fact that we're going to focus on
here so notice now that the policy
parameters only appear in terms of the
distribution of trajectories that we
might encounter under this policy and
this is again a little bit similar to
what we talked about for invitation
learning before we ran into imitation
learning we talked a lot about
distributions of states and
distributions of states and actions and
trying to find a policy that would match
the same state action distribution as
what was demonstrated by an expert today
we're not going to talk as much about
sort of state action distributions but
we are talking about sort of
distributions of trajectories that we
could encounter under our particular
policy so what's the gradient of this so
we want to take the gradient of this
function with respect to theta so we're
gonna go for this as follows we're gonna
rewrite what is the probability of a
trajectory under theta so I'm over tau
now we're going to do probability of tau
times alright first actually I'll move
it in
and then what we're gonna do is so then
what we're gonna do is we're gonna do
something simple where we just multiply
and divide by the same thing so we're
going to put in probability of tau given
theta divided by probability of tau
given theta times the derivative of the
probability of tau given theta and the
probability if we instead had a log so
if we were taking the derivative of log
of probability of tau given theta that
is exactly equal to the 1 over the
probability of tau given theta times the
derivative of P of tau given theta so we
can re-express this as follows
sum over tau R of tau P of tau given
theta times derivative with respect to
log of P of tau now so far that doesn't
necessarily seem like that's gonna be
very useful that so we've done that
that's a reasonable transformation but
we'll see shortly why that
transformation is helpful and in
particular the reason this
transformation is helpful is it's going
to be very useful when we think about
wanting to do all of this without
knowing the dynamics or reward models so
we're gonna need to be able to have a
you know get reward in terms of a
trajectory but we want to be able to
evaluate the gradient of a policy
without knowing the dynamics model and
this trick is going to help us get there
so when we do this this is often this is
often referred to as the likelihood
ratio now we can convert it and just say
well we notice that by doing this this
is actually exactly the same as the log
now why else does this start to look
like something that might be useful well
what do we have here we have if we this
is a sum over all trajectories of course
we don't necessarily have access to all
possible trajectories but we can sample
them so you could imagine starting to be
able to approximate this by running your
policy a number of times
sampling a number of trajectories
looking at the reward of those and then
taking the derivative with respect to
this probability of trajectory given
theta so typically we're going to do
this by just running the policy M times
and then that P if they tell given theta
we're gonna just approximate that by the
following
so that part drops out we're just going
to weigh all of the trajectories that we
got during our sampling uniformly and
then we look at the reward of that
trajectory and the log of PF Tau given
theta so what is happening in this case
okay so this is saying that the gradient
is this sort of the rule where do we get
times the log of the probability of that
trajectory for the reward word
associated a word times theta so what's
happening in that case so in this case
we have a function which for our case is
the reward which is sort of measuring
how good that particular you know
trajectory is or how good that sample is
and so what this is doing is we're just
moving up in the trajectory of the log
probability of that sample based on how
good it is so we want to push up our
parameters that are responsible for us
getting samples which are good so we
want to have parameters in our policy
that are going to cause us to execute
trajectories that give us high reward so
if we think of just sort of here f of X
again is the reward we this is our going
to be our policy a parametrized policy
we want to increase the weight of things
in our space that lead to high reward so
if this is our
f of X which is our reward function and
this is the probability of our
trajectories then we want to rewrite our
policy to try to increase the
probability of trajectories that yield
high reward so you would end up having
larger gradients towards things that
have high value high reward okay so then
the next question is if I'm going to do
this and I have to be able to
approximate the second term which is
this log you know the derivative with
respect to the probability of a
trajectory under some parameters so I
have to be able to figure out what is
the probability of a trajectory under a
set of parameters we can do that as
follows and so this is going to be Delta
Theta a log of the product of M U of s 0
so this is our initial starting stage
the probability of our initial starting
state times the product over J equals 0
to t minus 1 of the probability of
observing the next state given the
action that was taken times the
probability of taking that action under
our current policy so there's like
another bracket at the end and so since
this is log we can just decompose this
so this is going to be equal to delta
theta of log of mu of s naught plus
delta theta
sum over Delta Theta because it's a log
term of Jake will 0 to t minus 1 of log
the transition model remember we don't
know this a general this is unknown
we're just gonna hopefully end up with
an expression which means we don't need
to have it and what I is indexing here
is which trajectory we're on yeah it's
sum over J equals 0 to t minus 1 and
this is going to be our actual policy
parameters
alright can anybody tell me why this is
a useful decomposition and whether or
not it looks like we're gonna need to so
let me just parameters all of these
things does this look hopeful in terms
of us not needing to know what the
dynamics model is how about everybody
just take a second talk to your neighbor
and then tell me which of these terms
are going to be 0 so we're taking the
derivative with respect to theta and
which of these terms depend on theta
remember theta is what determines your
policy parameters theta is what
determines what action you take in a
given state all right I'm gonna do a
quick poll and so I'm gonna call these
items one two and three does the first
term depend on theta raise your hand if
yes is your handed no great okay yep so
this is independently as this can be 0
raise your hand if the second term is
independent of theta great so this goes
to 0 so the only thing we have less is
this which is great so the nice thing
and so now it sort of becomes more clear
why we did this weird log transformation
because when we did this weird log
transformation it allowed us to take
this product of the probability of the
action that we took and the state
transitions then instead we can
decompose it into sums and now once we
see that we decompose it into sums we
can apply the derivative separately and
that means some of these terms just
directly disappear
which is really cool so it means that we
don't actually need to know what the
transition model is we don't need to
have a explicit representation yeah
question and name first please
and the question is I was wondering
doesn't the dynamics of the system
depend on the policy though in general
question is does the dynamics of the
system depend on the policy absolutely
but only through this part so it's like
the agent gets to pick what action they
take but once they pick that the
dynamics is independent of the agent and
so it's this decoupling so if you have a
different policy you will absolutely get
different trajectories but the way in
which you get different trajectories is
only affected by the policy in terms of
the actions that are selected and then
the environment will determine sort of
the next states that you get and so we
don't need to know that in terms of
estimating the impact of the actions on
the environment it'll also come through
in terms of the rewards you get because
the rewards you get are also a function
of the state so you'll absolutely visit
different parts of the state depending
on the actions you take any other
questions
and this one make sure I understand how
to get the estimate for the probability
of how giveaways and theta I mean looks
like we're just saying episodes and this
one showed up
you know I times gonna be high over that
is that what we're doing here is that
correct
great question so here's asking you know
this is what I put here is just one of
those internal terms that would occur
for one I yes so what we're doing here
is we're saying we're gonna take this
policy we're going to run it M times
well part not going to get any
trajectories that are identical and what
we're gonna do is compute this log of
the probability of trajectory for each
of those separately and then sum them up
you might end up with that I mean you
know in deterministic cases you might or
if you do buddy doesn't have a lot of
stochasticity and neither does your
policy you might end up with multiple
trajectories that are identical in
general or your trajectories will be
completely different and so will your
estimate of their local gradients so
this is really nice we're gonna end up
with this situation where we only have
to be able to have an analytic form for
the derivative of our policy with
respect to our parameters so we still
need and we'll talk about this a little
bit more later we still need this we
have to evaluate this this is about how
we parameterize our policy and if we
want this to be analytic we need to have
parameterised our policy in a way that
we can compute this exactly for any
state in action so we'll talk more about
some ways you know some policy
parameters ations which make this
computation analytic and nice in other
cases you might have to estimate this
thing itself by you know brute force or
computation or finite differences or
something but if we choose a particular
form of parametrize policy then this
part is gonna be analytic so another
thing is I don't find this but I I don't
find this additional terminology
particularly helpful but it's used all
over the place that I want to introduce
it which is people often call this part
a score function just a score function
which is not particularly helpful I
think but nevertheless is often used is
called this that's the quantity that we
are just talking about needing to be
able to evaluate so this really gets
into
hey well-well we'll write it out again
so when we take the derivative of the
value function we approximate that by
getting M samples and we sum over I
equals 1 to M and we look at the reward
for that try that trajectory and then we
sum over these per step score functions
anybody read that in the back yeah ok
great yeah so these are sort of our
score functions these are our score
functions can be evaluated but for every
single state action pair that we saw and
we do not need to know the dynamics
model so the policy gradient theorem
slightly generalizes this how is it
going to generalize this note in this
case what we're doing here is we're this
is for the episodic setting and this is
for when we just take our raw raw or
award functions so we look at the sum of
rewards for that trajectory and then we
weigh it by this sort of derivative with
respect to our policy parameters it
turns out that we can also slightly
generalize this and let's say I'm going
to call so this is a value function
let's say that we had slightly different
objective functions we talked before
about how we could have a posada Kragh
ward or average reward per time step or
average value so we could either have
our objective function be equal to our
normal value for episodic or we could
have it equal to what I'm going to call
J ABR which is average or word per time
step or
we could have it as average value let's
say we're always continuing and we want
to average over the distribution of
states that we encounter so we could
think about that scenario - turns out in
all of those cases as you can do a
similar derivation to what we did here
for the episodic case and what we find
is that we have the derivative of our
objective function which now can be kind
of any one of these different objective
functions is equal to the expected value
under that the current policy of the
derivative with respect to just those
policy parameters times Q and sutnar
umberto in Chapter thirteen which we
also reference on the on the schedule
have a nice discussion about a number of
these different issues and so again
we're not going to talk too much about
these slightly other different objective
functions but just know that this all
can be extended to the continuing case
okay so what we've said here so far is
that we have this approximation where
what we do is we just take our policy we
run it out five M times for each of
those times we get a whole sequence of
states and actions and rewards and then
we average and this is an unbiased
estimate of the policy gradient but it's
very noisy so this is gonna be unbiased
and noisy if you think about what we saw
before for things like Monte Carlo
methods it should look vaguely familiar
same sort of spirit right we have just
running out our policy we're gonna get
some sum of rewards just like what we
got in Monte Carlo estimates but so
it'll be unbiased estimate of the
gradient so it's unbiased estimate of
the gradient estimate of gradient
but noisy so what can make this actually
practical there's a number of different
techniques for doing that but some of
the things we'll start to talk about
today are temporal structure and
basslines okay
so how do we fix this we're going to
start to look at you know fixes temporal
structure baselines and before we keep
going on this based on what I just said
in terms of Monte Carlo estimates and
what are some of you guys's ideas for
how we could maybe reduce the variance
of this estimate based on stuff we've
seen so far in class like what are the
alternative to cut of Monte Carlo
methods exactly right so dig in said
could use bootstrapping yeah so we've
repeatedly seen that we have this
trade-off between bias and variance and
that bootstrapping like temporal
difference methods that we saw in cue
learning that you're doing in DQ n can
be helpful in reducing variance and
speeding the spread of information so
yeah so we could absolutely do things
like bootstrapping um to kind of replace
R with something else or use a covariant
in addition to our to try to reduce the
variance of R all right so what we're
gonna do now is we're first gonna do
something that doesn't go all the way to
there but tries to at least leverage the
fact that we're in a temporal temporal
app process okay and for any of you who
have played around with important
sampling before this is closely related
to per decision importance sampling and
basically the thing that we're gonna
exploit is the fact that the rewards I
can only the temporal structure is doing
I'll write it out first okay so what we
had before is we said that
the river with respect to theta of the
expected value of tau of the return is
equal to the expected value under the
trajectories you could get of the sum
over T equals zero to t minus one of RT
so just the summer forwards you'd get
times this sum over T equals zero to t
minus one or if your derivative with
respect to your policy parameters that's
what we had before so we just sum up all
of our rewards and then we'd multiply
that by the sum over all of the
gradients of our policy at every single
action state pair we got in that
trajectory so let's think about doing
this for a single reward instead of
looking at the whole sum of rewards so
let's just look at we take the
derivative with respect to theta of
expected value of our T prime so this is
just a single time step forward that we
might encounter you know along our
trajectory and that's going to be equal
to the expected value of RT prime times
sum over T equals zero to T prime of
this derivative so this is gonna look
almost exactly the same as before except
the only key difference here is that I'm
only summing up to T Prime so we're only
summing up you can think of this as just
like a short introductory I'm looking at
the product of the states and the
actions and the rewards that I reached
all the way up to when I got to our t
prime so I don't have to sum all the way
over the future ones so we can take this
expression and now we can sum over all
time steps
so this says what's the expected reward
or the derivative with respect to the
reward for time step T prime now I'm
gonna just sum that and that's gonna be
the same as my first expression so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna say V of ADA
is equal to the derivative respect to
theta IVR and I'm going to sum up that
internal expression so I'm gonna sum
over T prime is equal to zero to t minus
1 RT prime and then insert that second
expression so all I did is I put that in
there and I summed over T prime is equal
to zero all the way up to t minus 1 and
then what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
reorder this and this by making the
following observation so if we think
about how many terms one of these
particular log pi theta H es T appears
in so if we look at log of Pi theta a 1
s 1 so if you look at how many times
that appears that appears for the early
rewards and it appears for all the later
rewards too okay this is gonna appear
for our 1 this is gonna appear for our 2
it's gonna clear all the way up to our
team right team is 1 because we're
always summing over everything before
that T prime okay so what we're gonna do
now is we're gonna take those terms and
we're gonna just reorganize those so
some of these terms appear a whole bunch
of times some of them the last one the
log of Pi theta of a t minus 1 st minus
1 it's only gonna appear once it's only
responsible for helping dictate the very
final reward so we can use that insight
to just slightly reorganize this
equation as follows so now we're gonna
say this is equal to the expected value
of sum over T equals 0 to t minus 1 so
notice before I had put the T Prime on
the outside and the T was on the inside
and now what I'm gonna do is put the T
on the outside and I'm gonna say I've
got Delta Theta
log PI theta a TST x sum over T prime is
equal to T all the way to t minus one of
our T prime so all I've done is I've
reorganized that son yes is it yeah yeah
on the second line in the bottom is it
supposed to be the derivative is that
the value function with respect to theta
and at the very left yeah okay oh sorry
do you mean this would be the derivative
of this yes okay so what we've done in
this case it was we've reorganized the
son we've just recollected terms in a
slightly different way but it's gonna be
in a useful way
so just move this up and I'll move this
one down
so right now we're still working on the
temporal structure what is this gonna
allow us to do well that second term
there should look somewhat familiar what
that saying here is that saying what
does their word we get starting at time
step T all the way to the end and that's
just the return so we had to previously
define that when we are talking about
like Monte Carlo methods etc that we
could always just look at RT this is
just equal to the return the return for
the rest of the episode starting in time
step T on Episode by so that that should
look very familiar to what we had seen
in Monte Carlo methods for we could
always say from this state in action
what was the summer of rewards we get
starting that same action till the end
of the episode so it means we can
re-express the derivative with respect
to theta as a product separately one
over m sum over all of the trajectories
were summing over sum over all the time
steps the derivative with respect to
theta of our actual policy parameter
times just the return and this is going
to be a slightly lower variance estimate
than before so instead of us having to
sort of separately sum up all of our
words and then we multiply that by the
full sum of all of these derivatives of
the logs
we're only kind of needing to take this
sum of the logs for some of the reward
terms essentially and so we can reduce
the variance in that case because in
some ways what this is doing this is
saying like for every single reward
because you could reassemble rewards for
every single one of those rewards you
have to sum it by sort of the full
trajectory in terms of the derivative of
the gradient the derivative of the
policy parameters and now we're saying
you don't have to
multiply that by all of those you only
have to multiply it by the ones that are
relevant for that particular reward that
means that you're gonna have a slightly
lower variance estimator so when we do
this we can end up with what's known as
reinforce which here's heard of
reinforced a number of people not
everybody we enforce this one of the
most common reinforcement learning
policy grading algorithms so you get the
reinforced algorithm so what how it
works is you the algorithm is you
initialize NIT data randomly you always
will have to first decide on how your
parametrizing your policy so somewhere
you're ready to fight decided how your
parametrizing your policy now you're
going to set the values for that policy
randomly and then for each episode so
you're gonna run an episode with that
policy and you're gonna gather a whole
bunch of actions and rewards and this is
sampled from your current policy so you
sample your current policy according to
seven from your current policy you get a
trajectory and then for every step in
that trajectory you're gonna update your
policy parameters so for every time step
inside of that episode we're gonna
update our policy parameters so it's
gonna be the same as before times some
learning rate Boop I will not use W
there alpha times the derivative spec to
Theda log pi theta dat GT where GT is
just in this episode what is the sum of
rewards from st 80 onwards so that's the
just the normal returned like what we
had with Monte Carlo methods so just
like what we did wrong estimating like
the linear value function and we were
using rewards from the state and action
onwards we're gonna do the same thing
here except for we're gonna be updating
the policy parameters and we do this
many many many times and then at the end
we return the theta parameters that is
right so in this case you after you do
all the updates for one Episode so you
give you these incremental updates and
then at the end of doing all of your
incremental updates then you get another
episode with your new updating
parameters yeah so since we're doing
every time I says um this should be an
unbiased estimate of the I it should
still be an unbiased estimate of the
gradient it's stochastic but we there's
not a notion of state and actions in the
same way this will be asymptotically
consistent it's a good question
so the notion of a state in action in
this case is different because we have
just these policy parameters so not
estimating the value of a state in
action here so this is certainly
asymptotically consistent I think it's
still just unbiased if I if I reconsider
that later I'll tender Piazza Post but I
think it's still just an unbiased
estimator of the gradient it's a good
question okay
so when I got back to slide notes I
think the last thing I just wanted well
I mentioned a car things we'll one
critical question here is whether or not
or how to compute this differential with
respect to the policy parameters so I
think it's useful to talk about you know
what are the classes of policies that
often people consider that I have nice
differentiable forms so some of the
classes people considers are things like
soft max gaussians and neural networks
those are probably the most common so
and what do I mean by that I mean that's
how we're gonna actually just
parameterize our policy so let's just
look at an example so soft max is where
we simply have a linear combination of
features and we take sort of an
exponential weight of them so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna have some
features or very state and action space
and we're gonna multiply them by some
weights our parameters these are our
parameters and then to actually get a
probability of taking an action so if we
want to have our policy where we say
what is the probability of action given
a state we're gonna take the exponential
of these weighted features so we have e
to the 5 T theta divided by the sum over
all actions so notice this is a
reasonable thing to do when our action
space is discrete
I should space discrete so lot of Atari
games a lot of different scenarios you
do have a discrete action space so you
couldn't just take this exponential
divided by the normalized sum over the
exponential and that immediately yields
our parametrized policy class and so
then if we want to be able to take the
derivative of this with respect to the
log that's quite nice because we have
Exponential's here and we have log chart
we're taking
the log of this so we want to be able to
compute this term from this sort of
parametrized policy class what we get is
the derivative with respect to theta of
log of this type of parameterize policy
is just equal to our features so this is
whatever feature representation we're
using like in the case of the locomotion
robotic case this would be like all the
different this could be something like
you know angles or joints or things like
that so this is whatever feature ization
were using minus the expected value for
theta of your parameters with an
exponent with your expected value over
all the actions you might take under
that policy so it's sort of saying the
features that you observed versus the
sort of average feature averaged
averaged over the action so that's
differentiable and you can solve it then
it gives you an analytic form another
thing that's really popular is a
Gaussian policy and why might this be
good well this might be good because
often we have continuous actions faces
so this is good if we have discrete
action spaces often we have continuous
action spaces this is very common in
controls and robotics I have a number of
different parameters and their
continuous scalar values that you want
to be able to set and what we could say
here is that say we use mu of s might be
a linear combination of state features
times some parameter and let's imagine
for simplicity right now that we have a
variance but that's static so we could
also consider the case where it stopped
but we're gonna assume that we have some
variance term that is fixed this is not
a parameter this is not something we're
gonna try to learn we're just gonna be
trying to learn the theta that's
defining our new function and then our
policy is going to be a Gaussian so a is
going to be drawn from a Gaussian using
this
they're features so we compare our
current state to the mean and then we
select an action with respect to that
and the score function in this case is
the derivative of this Gaussian so score
is a derivative of this Gaussian
function which ends up being a minus mu
of s times our parameterization of the
state features divided by Sigma squared
so again it can be done analytically and
the other really common one is deep
neural networks so those are those are
the sort of very common forms and AI
that people use we're going to talk next
time about another common way before we
finish and we're gonna do spend about
five minutes to do some early class
feedback it's really helpful for us to
figure out what's helping you learn what
things you think could be improved and
so what I'm gonna do right now is open
if you guys could go to Piazza it would
be great if you can fill this out all
everything is anonymous and my goal is
to give feedback for you guys on
Wednesday about this so I just let me
see if I could redo that so it's posted
okay let me see if I can I'll pin it so
it's easier to find so it should be pin
now or at the very top yep
so mid class feedback survey if you go
to Piazza it's very short survey can
give us information back that would be
great what we'll do next time is we'll
continue to talk about policy search
we're going to talk about baselines
which is another way to reduce variance
and this again is a super active area of
research so there's a ton of work on
deep reinforcement learning and policy
gradients and so we'll talk about some
of that work and then you'll have a
chance to play around with this and do
it get sort of hands-on experience with
policy gradients after the midterm so
we'll release an assignment about this
at post the midterm and that will be the
third assignment